if you want to be an entrepreneur the
most important thing is to be customer
obsessed don't satisfy your customers
figure out how to absolutely Delight
them that is the number one thing you
have got to have some passion for the
arena that you're going to develop and
work in because otherwise you're going
to be competing against people who do
have passion for that and they're going
to build better products and services
you can't be a mercenary you have to be
a missionary missionaries build better
products and services they always win
the mercenaries are just trying to make
money the missionaries always end up
making more money you have to take risk
you have to be willing to take risk if
you aren't going to take risk you're
probably you know it's probably already
being done and they're being done well
by many many people so you've got to
have something that might not work and
so you have to accept that your business
is going to be in many ways an
experiment and it might fail and that's
okay that's what risk is in Amazon we
still take risks all the time and we
encourage it we talk about failure we
need big failures if we're going to be
moving the needle we need to have
billion dollar dollar scale failures and
if we're not we're not swinging hard
enough need motivation
believe Nation hey
it's the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Jeff Bezos and my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
rule number two take action stress
primarily comes from not taking action
over something that you can have some
control over so if I find that some
particular thing is causing me to have
stress that's a a a a a warning flag for
me what it means is there's something
that I haven't completely identified
perhaps in my conscious mind that is
bothering me and I haven't yet taken any
action on it I find as soon as I
identify it and make the first phone
call or send off the first email message
or whatever it is that we're going to do
to start to address that situation even
if it's not solved the mere fact that
we're addressing it dramatically reduces
any stress that might come from it so
stress comes from ignoring things that
you shouldn't be ignoring I think in
large part so stress doesn't come people
get stress uh wrong all the time in my
opinion stress doesn't come from hard
work for example you know you can be
working incredibly hard and loving it
and likewise you can be out of work and
Incredibly stressed over that
so and likewise if you kind of use the
you know use that as an analogy for what
I was just talking about if you're out
of work but you're going through you
know a disciplined approach of you know
a series of job interviews and so on and
working to remedy that situation you're
going to be a lot less stressed than if
you're just worrying about it and doing
nothing rule number three disagree and
commit I have to if I have a new idea
that I am in love with and I want to see
it pursued I do have to build support
for it just like anybody would because
you need very smart people to embrace
the idea and move it forward we have a
framework at Amazon it's one of our
leadership principles it's called
disagree and commit and that is
extremely useful
um because after you've discussed an
idea you do need to make a decision and
move forward and people the whole team
needs to really commit to that when I
really feel strongly about something and
the team disagrees with me I have a
phrase that I like to use which is
helpful which is I want you to gamble
with me on this it's very different from
from phrasing that never mind because
the truth is when you're in a position
like that where nobody knows what the
right answer is you're not saying I'm
right on this go do this you're saying I
want you to gamble with me on this
because I don't know if it's right
either I disagree and commit all the
time and I promise the people when I do
it I very clear I don't agree with this
I think it's probably not going to work
um but I will never say I told you so
and I'm going to be on your team I will
do everything I can to make it work rule
number four create great products you
should wake up
worried terrified every morning but
don't be worried about our competitors
because they're never going to send us
any money anyway let's be worried about
our customers and stay heads down
focused and so I you know there these
are Big most of these are Big markets
another way to answer your your question
about competitors in Walmart is just say
look they can succeed fabulously and it
won't stop us from succeeding these
retail markets are huge so we can we it
often doesn't make sense for us to think
of it as a pitched battle you know
sometimes
um people think about business as it's
kind of like a a sporting event there's
a winner and a loser it's not a zero-sum
game it usually isn't yeah I'm sure
there are cases where but most often
Industries succeed so I can tell you I
think e-commerce is succeeding and the
way we think about it nobody else has
fail for us to do well I think ebooks is
like that I think they're going to be
many winners I think ebooks is going to
be a huge industry well there are many
competitors now I mean you've got Barnes
and Noble is one of them Sony is another
now and they'll be more as another but I
have a list of 50 competitors that we
could walk through I mean you know all
over the world doing different things
and our focus is going to be you know
what we'll try to pay attention to those
competitors but we're not going to
obsess over them we're going to obsess
over readers and that because those are
the people who are buying that device
and we're going to make and it's not
just a business for us it's a mission
for us and missionaries build better
products also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all of the
Lessons Learned in this video as well as
pull out our three favorite learnings
and quotes that will inspire you to
actually do something the worksheet will
also give you space to write down what
your key takeaways are are and your
specific plan of action to make sure
you're getting results if you want the
worksheet designed specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five think long term
our mission is Earth's most
customer-centric company I don't know
what that means well let me I'll give
you an example
um
right after World War II
morita-san the guy who founded Sony
set as the mission for Sony
that they were going to make Japan known
for quality
I have to remember this was a time when
Japan was known for cheap copycat
products
and morita-san said he didn't say we're
going to make Sony known for Quality he
said we're gonna make Japan known for
Quality he he chose a mission for Sony
that was bigger than Sony
and when we talk about Earth's most
customer-centric company we have a
similar
idea in mind we want other companies to
look at Amazon and see us as a standard
Bearer for obsessive focus on the
customer as opposed to obsessive focus
on the competitor
so that's one of the reasons we work on
differentiated products it's one of the
reasons we take a long-term
viewpoint on things you can't really do
the right thing for customers if you're
short-term oriented and if you're going
to invent new things you've also got to
be able this goes along with long-term
orientation you've got to be willing to
endure a lot of criticism you know if
you're going to put Kindle is a good
example if you're going to put your back
into Reinventing a 500 year old industry
some folks are going to get ornery
rule number six
like it's day one day two
is stasis
followed
by irrelevance
followed by excruciating
painful decline
followed by Death
yeah
and that
is why
it is always
day one rule number seven take more
risks I um went to my boss and said to
him you know I'm gonna go do this crazy
thing and I'm gonna start this uh this
company selling books online and this is
something that I've already been talking
to him about in a sort of more General
context but then he said let's go on a
walk we went on a two-hour walk in
Central Park in New York City
and the conclusion of that was this he
said you know this actually sounds like
a really good idea to me but it sounds
like it would be a better idea for
somebody who didn't already have a good
job
and he convinced me to think about it
for 48 hours before making a final
decision and so I went away and and and
was trying to find the right framework
in which to make that kind of big
decision and you know I'd already talked
to my wife about this and she was very
supportive and said look you know you
can count me in 100
whatever you want to do you know it's
true she had married this kind of you
know fairly stable guy in a stable
career path and now he wanted to go do
this crazy thing but she was 100
supportive so it really was a decision
that I had to make for myself
and the and the framework I found which
made the decision incredibly easy was
what what I called which only a nerd
would call a regret minimization
framework so I wanted to project myself
forward to age 80. and say okay now I'm
looking back on my life I want to have
minimize the number of regrets I have
and you know I knew that when I was 80 I
was not going to regret having tried
this I was not going to regret having
wanted you know trying to participate in
this thing called the internet that I
thought was going to be a really big
deal I knew that if I failed I wouldn't
regret that but I knew the one thing I
might regret is not ever having tried
and I knew that that would haunt me
every day and so when I thought about it
that way it was an incredibly easy
decision
uh and I think that's a very good it's
it's if you can project yourself out to
age 80 and sort of think what will I
think at that time it gets you away from
some of the daily pieces of confusion
you know I left uh this Wall Street firm
in the middle of the year when you do
that you walk away from your annual
bonus and that's the kind of thing then
the short term can confuse you but if
you think about the long term then you
can really make good life decisions that
you won't regret later rule number eight
be a good role model one of the things
that we know about
uh Amazon as a role model for this is
that our business is it's a difficult
challenge for us because we have deep
large physical infrastructure we're not
only moving information around we're
moving packages around we deliver 10
billion items more than 10 billion items
a year this is real physical
infrastructure at real scale and so we
can make the argument and we plan to do
so passionately that if we can do this
anyone can do this it's going to be
challenging but we know we can do it and
we know we have to do it where are we
today
today we're at 40 renewable energy we've
done that by building 15 utility scale
solar and wind farms we've put rooftop
installations on fulfillment centers and
sortation centers around the world
uh where are we going well on renewable
energy by 2024 we're committing to be at
80 percent renewable energy and by 2030
we're committing to be at 100 percent
renewable energy
we're also we have a lot of delivery
events and they all burn fossil fuels
today I'm incredibly excited to announce
that we have just placed an order for
100
000 electric delivery events they'll be
built by a company called rivien this is
another example of something very
important I want to talk about which is
that when you make a pledge like the
climate pledge it will drive the economy
to start to build products and services
that these large companies need to meet
those commitments this is why we
invested in rivian we invested 440
million dollars in rivian that's part of
what I'm so excited about as this
economy develops and people get serious
about being carbon zero through real
changes to their real business
activities that is going to be a
gigantic signal to the marketplace to
start inventing develop developing these
new technologies that these global
companies will need to be able to meet
this commitment and so that's another
reason we have to work together we have
to get a number of companies to sign up
for this to really drive that market
signal in a strong way Amazon is large
but if we get lots of large companies to
agree to the same thing that would be an
even stronger signal to the market that
together with the fact that the supply
chains are so interconnected it becomes
the only way to do it and that's with
collaboration rule number nine get in
the arena first of all
I love space I have been a space lover
since I was a five-year-old boy
and I feel like I won the lottery with
Amazon I know I won the lottery and uh
and now I'm investing those lottery
winnings in blue origin which is uh the
space company
um we built we're built we are flying a
sub orbital tourism vehicle and we'll
start taking people up hopefully in 2018
that's coming right up working on it for
more than 10 years
hopefully this one this is this
overnight success is taking longer than
10 years I don't know we'll see you know
uh and we're also building an orbital
vehicle called New Glen new Shepherd is
named it for Alan Shepard the first
American in space he went on a
suborbital journey new Glen is named
after the American hero John Glenn who
was the first American to orbit the
Earth and
so these are both these are reusable
boosters fully reusable that's the key
to lowering the cost our vision of blue
origin is that we want millions of
people living and working in space and
my personal hope is that I live long
enough to see
um the kind of dynamism in space I want
to see a whole economy entrepreneurs in
space that I got to witness over the
last 20 years on the internet you know
um the the problem with being an
entrepreneur in the space arena is that
the price of admission is so darn High
so it you know to do interesting things
in Space the beginning you know kind of
the beginning entry level is a few
hundred million dollars
so you're not going to get you know two
kids in their dorm room doing something
amazing in space whereas that's
literally what happened to Facebook
right so on the internet because the
price of admission is so low
you can get these amazing experiments
where like one kid in the dorm room does
something and it turns into Facebook and
or you know Amazon's case you know I
started this thing with an incredibly
small amount of capital
and the you know it was able to grow
because we didn't need a lot to get to
begin with the heavy lifting was in
place for Amazon right so I didn't need
to build a transportation Network it
existed already it was ups and the Royal
Mail and the U.S Postal Service and
Deutsche Post and so on and so on I
didn't have to build a
telecommunications backbone to connect
with my customers it was there it was
called the internet and in fact the
internet was resting on top of the long
distance phone network at that time you
guys remember the dial-up motive some of
you do some of you are too young to some
of you should go to a museum and see a
dial-up modem what was that sound yeah
and so
my one I I recently showed a group of
youngsters a pay phone I came across one
and I was like my God guys come over
here this may be the last one you have
to see it
um and uh so you know the point is that
Amazon was got to rest on top of we
didn't have to build a payment system it
already existed it was called the credit
card
um computers were already on every desk
thanks to you know Microsoft IBM and
apple and but what were they being used
for to play games not to buy things on
Amazon and so all that heavy lifting was
in place and I want to you know my
greatest uh uh uh I would have such a
good feeling if I could be an 80 year
old guy and laying there thinking about
my life if I could say look there is
um now a bunch of entrepreneurs in space
because I took my Amazon lottery
winnings and built the heavy lifting
infrastructure that does take billions
of dollars in capex to lower for the
cost of access to space that's how you
get millions of people living at work
and by the way we need that for those of
you who like to think about the future
at all you can do a simple calculation
you know you we can argue about
um you know what limited resources on
Earth and so on and so on but here's a
calculation that you cannot argue with
which is you take current Baseline
energy usage on Earth compound it at
just a few percent a year for just a few
hundred years and you have to cover the
entire surface of the Earth in solar
cells
so
you have to we're going to have to
decide do we want a society of
pioneering invention expansion growth or
do we want a society of stasis
and personally I believe because the
Earth is finite and if you want a
society of stasis I think it's good
first of all I don't personally believe
the stasis is even compatible with
freedom so I think for me that's a big
problem second of all
it's going to be dull stasis is going to
be very dull you don't want to live in
the stasis world and so of course we're
going to continue to get more efficient
too we have been for hundreds of years
we've been getting more productive more
efficient that's that trend is going to
continue but even so we're going to want
to use more energy more energy per
capita and also I don't want to
stabilize population I would love for
there to be a trillion humans in the
solar system with a trillion humans we
would have a thousand Einsteins and a
thousand mozarts it'd be an incredible
symbol don't you want that dynamism it'd
be so much interesting my this is for
your great great grandchildren but what
kind of world do you want them to live
in I want them to live in that expansive
world that is you know learning more
about the universe and moving out
throughout the solar system so that we
have to do it and um anyway so it's fun
to work on that and uh uh uh you know I
get I have a I won so many lotteries in
my life
um I have the best parents in the world
my mom Jackie and my dad Mike my mom had
me when she was 17 in Albuquerque New
Mexico she was still in high school it
was not cool
and she did an amazing job my dad Mike
is a Cuban immigrant who came here when
he was 16 without his parents did an
amazing job so those are the things that
are your little gifts in life you get
sometimes you get my greatest admiration
by the way is withheld for those people
and I know several of them who had
terrible parents
and still somehow made it through that's
hard
um that was I had the opposite so I got
lucky I rule number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
protect our planet climate change gives
us a powerful reason to invest in nature
in too many parts of the world nature is
already flipping from a carbon sink to a
carbon source
this is a profound and Urgent danger to
us all
now in this critical year and what we
all know is the decisive decade
we must all stand together to protect
our world
this three billion dollars in pledges
will drive a new three-fold nature
agenda for the Bezos Earth fund focused
simultaneously on conservation
restoration and food transformation we
must conserve what we still have we must
restore what we've lost and we must grow
what we need to live without degrading
the planet for future generations to
come the question is simple
will we in this room work together do
the hard work together
the gift our children and grandchildren
and improving natural world
I know the answer is yes
and I look forward to working with all
of you on this important and rewarding
Journey thank you
how do we get young people re-engaged
with government service
well
I think one thing and I I look at this
at Amazon too so I I don't think it's
just government service I think a lot of
these government organizations are large
organizations
and large organizations have a set of
problems and I worry about this at
Amazon I want us to have
this the scope and capabilities of a
large organization but the spirit and
heart of a small startup company
and and I and I think that so large
organizations one of the things
that happens is that the rate of the
decision-making velocity goes down and
it gets hard for large organizations to
make decisions quickly it's trivial for
a 50-person startup
they make decisions like this but a 500
000 person company like Amazon or a
giant government agency there's a lot of
levels of review and different things
and it can really slow and by the way
that young people don't want to work at
a company with a slow decision-making
process it's just not as fun as working
at a startup company or somewhere else
where so I think you can do that and
even in a large organization I think if
you if the leadership this is all about
leadership if the leadership focuses on
increasing the decision-making velocity
of the organization you will get
everybody will be happier it's more fun
um everybody will be happier at work and
you'll get younger people because that's
what they want you can also do every
single person who works in a large
company you get to decide you're going
to help increase the decision making
velocity are you going to bring energy
to the room we all know we all have
those people we work with them
as soon as they walk in the room
the whole room the energy level goes up
somehow they bring energy to that
conference room and we also all work
with people who are the opposite like
the second they walk in the room the
whole room
deflates
and you don't want to be that second guy
you want to be that first guy and you
and we all get to choose that we all get
to decide that so anyway I think you can
do it in big organizations and I think
one of the things that makes big
organizations less attractive to young
people is just
sometimes we're slow and and you can
fight that and you can fix it if you are
a lottery winner as I am then one of the
things that you you get a chance to do
at some point in your life is to be a
philanthropist and so uh I you know I
didn't grow up hoping you know boy maybe
I'll be a threat philanthropist one day
that wasn't ever on my list of you know
archaeologists astronaut um those things
I wanted to be physicist I never
I think in large part because I never
expected to have the means to be a
philanthropist but I think that if you
win a lottery uh of of this kind of size
that one of the things that that uh that
over time you have an obligation to do
is to think about the ways that that uh
that that wealth can be used in a highly
leveraged way I also think by the way
it's really easy to give away money in
highly unleveraged ways where it's just
a waste of money and I suspect that it
takes as much sort of time energy focus
and hard work
to effectively give away money as it
does to
get it in the first place what do you
see as the biggest challenges or risk in
operating in the space domain
well let's start with the fundamental
principle
you never want a fair fight
that's for a boxing ring
outside of a boxing ring
a fair fight
it's just bad strategy
and it means you didn't prepare properly
and as you pointed out this nation has
enjoyed
incredible space dominance for so long
and it's changing because because uh
other other some of our potential
adversaries are
getting very sophisticated
and so how what for me or if I if I were
in your shoes the way I would think
about this is
in this new era
how are we going to maintain space
dominance what does it really mean and
you're going to need some fundamental
capabilities
um
you have to be able to go to space
more frequently
with less lead time if you look over
long periods of time you know look over
hundreds of years and look at the
average sort of life cycle of a new
technology what you find is that it's
getting compressed and compressed and
compressed so the rate of change is
getting faster and faster every decade
that goes by they're sort of more
important discoveries per unit time than
there were in the previous decade
and uh and and a lot of these
discoveries tend to uh uh you know have
two uses I mean Technologies and you
know tend to be agnostic with with
respect to whether they could be used
for good or used for evil and I think
that you know over the next 50 years
we are gonna
face a lot of very tough decisions as a
society in in how we make sure that we
are harnessing those Technologies for
good purposes
I think Liberty giving people the
freedom to uh you know as long as
they're not hurting somebody else do
what they want is super important I
think it's the Core Essence of the
American dream and I think at times we
as people get confused about it I mean I
think one of the things that you see
come up uh in in various places and
people talk about it under different
labels sometimes they talk about it as a
lack of personal responsibility and
other kinds of labels but what it really
is is is I think people should you know
carefully reread the first part of the
Declaration of Independence because I
think sometimes we as a society start to
get confused and think that we have a
right to happiness but if you read the
Declaration of Independence it talks
about life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness nobody has a right to
happiness you should have a right to
pursue it and I think the core of that
is Liberty if you looked at what you've
brought and the legacy of any Innovation
how would you describe that well I think
what you know the Amazon's what I would
hope Amazon's Legacy would be is Earth's
most customer-centric company what we
have always wanted to do
is raise the standard for what it means
to be customer-centric to such a degree
that other organizations whether they be
other companies or whether they be
hospitals or government agencies
whatever the organization is they should
look at Amazon as a role model and say
how can we be as customer-centric as
Amazon even if we editors I imagine
right hopefully competitors as well but
if we could make you know if that could
be our Legacy that we kind of raise the
general idea of what it means to be
customer-centric that would be a huge
accomplishment it would be accomplishing
a mission that's much bigger than
ourselves from the very beginning
in 1994 when I came across this fact
that the web was growing at 2300 a year
I was working on Wall Street very
specialized kind of Investment Bank
called a quantitative hedge fund a
company called de Shaw
and uh I uh when I decided I was going
to go do this crazy thing I went and
told my boss and he said well let's go
for a walk so we went on a two-hour walk
in Central Park
and uh he actually thought it was a good
idea it's a very smart guy his name is
David Shaw he's one of the few people I
know who has a fully developed left
brain a fully developed right brain just
a super smart guy and he said this is a
great uh idea but it would be a better
idea for somebody who didn't already
have a good job and
um and uh that was actually a compelling
argument to me and so I went away he
convinced me to think about it for two
more days and it was very hard to make
that decision and until I found the
right framework in which to make the
decision and I think because I know
there are a lot of people who are
interested in entrepreneurial activities
out there I think this could be useful
it's it's that it's the right framework
for me anyway to make the kind of
decision was a regret minimization
framework so I projected myself into the
future and I'm 80 years old and I'm
looking back on my life what do I want
to have done at that point want to
minimize all the regrets that I have and
I knew that when I was 80 there was no
chance that I would regret having walked
away from my 1994 Wall Street bonus or
any of that kind of thing I wouldn't
even remember that but I did think there
was a chance that I might regret not
having participated somehow and this
thing that I thought was going to be
very exciting called the internet
and uh and I also knew that if I tried
and failed I wouldn't regret that so
once I thought about it that way it
become became incredibly easy to make
that decision you need people who and
this is very tricky you need people who
are experts in a certain domain area
because the world is so complex today
it's really hard to invent something if
you're if you're not an expert if you
don't have the underlying tools at your
disposal and know what's going on you
can't you know invent something in
neurosurgery without knowing something
about neurosurgery
it's just going to be very difficult
because we're very Advanced and that's
true in every every field of endeavor
but to really be an inventor you have to
combine that expertise with The
Beginner's mind you have to have a
certain
childlike ability to not be trapped by
your expertise and that fresh look that
beginner's mind once you're an expert is
unbelievably hard to maintain but great
inventors are always looking they have a
certain Divine discontent and they they
may have seen something a thousand times
and still it occurs to them that that
thing even though they're accustomed to
it could be improved and that's you know
you have to look for people like that
and I also think cultures support that
you know you can't even if you're that
kind of person
if you're in a culture that doesn't
support failure you know willingness to
fail is critical for invention
willingness to be misunderstood for long
periods of time you know most inventions
don't really work that well in the
beginning they're clumsy they're little
toddlers they're always falling and
tripping
um and so you have to have a a a culture
in your organization that supports this
kind of stumbling and wandering uh you
know you want just because you're
wandering doesn't mean you're lost and
that's a really important thing to keep
in mind when you're trying to invent
there are a couple of other things that
are essential for Innovation and
invention that are not as fun
one of them is you have to have a
willingness to fail
you have to have a willingness to be a
misunderstood for long periods of time
if you do something in a new way
I don't care what it is
people are initially going to
misunderstand it relative to the
traditional way and they will
they'll be well-meaning critics
who you know genuinely want the best
outcome but they're worried about this
new way
and they'll also be of course
self-interested critics
who have a vested interest
in the traditional they have some Profit
Stream tied to the traditional way
um but but doing things and if you want
to if you never want to be criticized
for goodness sake don't do anything new
so
it's it's it's okay though if you have a
willingness to be misunderstood for long
periods of time if you have a
willingness to fail
then what you can do is you can ramp up
your rate of experimentation so
successful invention a successful
invention is inventions that customers
care about
it's actually relatively easy to invent
new things that customers don't care
about
but successful invention
if you want to do a lot of that you
basically have to increase your rate of
experimentation
and that you can think of as a process
how do you go about organizing your
systems
your
people all of your assets your own daily
life and how you spend time how do you
organize those things to increase your
rate of experimentation because not all
of your experiments are going to work I
think it's a very rare idea that can be
done by a single individual almost
everything that is going to change the
world solve a problem improve something
these are usually big efforts and they
require you know teams a team working
together to really get something
important done and that has been the
story of amazon.com at every step along
the way we've had a team here that is is
making this work I mean I don't know
even even at the smallest scale you have
to figure out how to get help from your
friends from your family members from
people that you can hire in those early
days I think without that it would never
work there are a few things I think if
you want to be an Innovative company
that you you have to do first of all I
think Innovation is a point of view you
have to actually select people that are
part of the company who want to innovate
and explore
um being a pioneering
company an Explorer company isn't for
everybody some people wake up in the
morning and they get their uh energy the
thing they think about in the shower as
they start their annual planning process
or however you want to think about it
with who are the three companies that
we're going to kill this year that's the
Conqueror mentality and it's a
competitor focused mentality instead of
a customer focused mentality
and there's nothing that that mentality
can succeed by the way so I'm not
claiming you know the pioneering
Explorer approach is the only uh
effective one
um but when you've when you attract
people who have the DNA of pioneers and
the DNA of explorers you build a company
of like-minded people who want to invent
and that's what they think about when
they get up in the morning how are we
going to work backwards from customers
and build a great service or a great
product
that's uh that's a key element in to to
invention okay and that part is Fun by
the way so if you're the right kind of
person and you like to invent you like
change uh and you everything you see as
you move about the world you think how
it could be improved that's just fun and
we at Amazon we've over the last 18 plus
years attracted a bunch of people like
that and we have a ton of fun doing it
sometimes you know we we expand into new
areas in two ways
um one is kind of you know from from a
customer need we will work from a
customer need to the skills that we need
and the other one is skills forward from
a skill set we have to a new set of
customers so Kendall is an example of a
customer need and you know so we don't
have any hardware skills this is we're
doing this for 10 years now but we'll go
back and we'll go if you go back and
have 10 years we had no Hardware team we
had to hire somebody to lead our
Hardware group and then build a harbor
team and build some institutional
competence at it and so on
that um that's a customer need backwards
approach and then skills forward a great
example of that is Amazon web services
we had the skills to do AWS we had
probably more distributed computing
expertise than anybody else in the world
because of the transactions transaction
systems are so complicated and hard to
build and we had a service oriented
architecture of great complexity
probably before anybody else and so we
saw we could kind of because we were
doing that we could kind of see the
future a little bit and decide to build
AWS which has turned into you know a
huge business in its own right
and that is uh you know you if you were
always
business is very situational and so
rules of thumb are good but they have to
be applied to the right situation so
sometimes the old
Maxim that you should stick to the
knitting is correct but sometimes the
adage that you should stick to the
knitting is wrong and uh you know a
senior Leader's job is to figure out in
which situation are you it's about
definitely about leaning into the future
um and so when you look at the kinds of
things that you want to be able to do
with your voice uh you know it it
changes for for those of you who have
used an echo the fact that it's always
on that you never have to charge it it's
always sitting there ready in your
kitchen or your bedroom or wherever you
put it the fact that you can talk to it
in in a natural way removes a lot of
barriers a lot of friction a lot of like
little tiny uh pieces of friction to be
able to do things to ask what the
weather is it's easier than taking your
phone out of your pocket and what what
has what people have found over and over
again is that by removing the tiniest
amounts of friction from ordinary
activities really people appreciate that
and and it improves customers lives we
are can we be
let's say China and India very
separately so we are winning in India
very very uh well
we have an amazing leader there a guy
named Ahmet who has been at Amazon for
15 years and you know here in the U.S
they moved back to India four or five
years ago to start Amazon India and that
team is is doing well they have passed
Flipkart they are the leader in India
now so that is you know similar to Japan
Germany the UK France those countries
are you know very in China the leader is
JD and we have we are totally adapting
our strategy in China we cannot run our
normal playbook in China it has to be
specialized and different so we're we're
doing that I know you have many
interests outside of Amazon tell me
about the 10 000 year clock
well I'm I'm building a clock a big
clock it's a kind of a Monumental scale
it's inside a mountain in West Texas
it's the invention of a brilliant guy
named Danny Hillis who had been thinking
about it for a long time and it's a
symbol for long-term thinking it's a
clock that you know you kind of think of
it it you know sort of ticks once a day
and you know dongs once a century and
the cuckoo comes out once a millennium
that sort of thing so it's a and it
keeps time it's a completely mechanical
clock it's powered by thermal night day
cycles it's a very sophisticated piece
of mechanical machinery and everything
is tested to last 10 000 years it keeps
time for that long there's a lot of
stuff to think through because it's
synchronized at solar noon and there
could be in 10 000 years it turns out
there could be three year periods where
you have no sunlight at solar noon
asteroids hit the earth and change the
axis of rotation of the earth we have to
account for things like that
um the and so beyond just the pr the
normal procession of the earth so it's a
very complicated mechanical piece of
equipment but what's the purpose you
would say this is an odd thing to do to
spend any time on
and
the I think symbols are really important
symbols can be very very valuable and we
have as a species become
so omnipotent on planet Earth that we're
really going to have to start thinking
longer term it can you know in a lot of
different ways it's it and
um and you can accomplish so much if you
think long term that you can't if you
think short term so if I said to you you
know I want you to take this Mission I
want you to solve world hunger in five
years
you would rightly just turn down that
mission you'd say that's not possible
why would you even bother trying but if
I said to you
let's solve world hunger in 100 years
now that's really that's actually much
more tractable now you can think about
it and you can say okay well how do we
create the preconditions that are
necessary to solve world hunger and so
long-term thinking is a huge lever and
uh and I think it gets harder to do as
the speed of of invention and
civilization changes in part because it
sometimes doesn't make sense to think
long term if everything is changing so
quickly that's why you know kind of
taking that back to the customer needs
that I was talking about before you need
to find those things that we know as a
society that will want even 100 years
from now and then make sure that we go
about go about working on those things
I've never seen you panic I've sort of
you stay the course and you sort of
stick to your script how do you do that
and how do you advise us to to sort of
internalize that as well as a strategy
well um I think that if you're
straightforward and clear about the way
that you're going to operate
then you can operate in whatever way in
whatever way you choose and and we don't
even take a position on whether our way
is the right way we just claim it's our
way but you know Warren Buffett has a
great uh saying along these lines he
says you can hold a ballet and that can
be successful and you can hold a rock
concert and that can be successful just
don't hold a ballet and advertise it as
a rock concert is there a particular
recipe that you have in terms of how you
actually innovate in that collaborative
culture
I think um and I don't I don't think
there's a particular recipe but there
are elements of what we do uh that I
think help so one of them is that inside
our culture we understand that even
though we have some big businesses new
businesses start out small and so you
know we it would be very easy for say
the person who runs our U.S books
category to say why are we doing these
experiments with things I mean you know
that generated you know a tiny bit of
Revenue last year
why don't we instead Focus those
resources and that uh you know that all
that brain power on this on the books
category where we which is a big
business for us and instead that would
be a natural thing to have happen but
instead inside Amazon you know when a
new business you know reaches some small
Milestone of sales email messages go
around and everybody's you know giving
virtual high fives for reaching that
Milestone and I think it's because we
know from our past experiences that big
things start small uh you know the
biggest Oak starts from an acorn and
you've got to recognize if you want to
do anything new
you've got to be willing to let that
Acorn grow into a little sapling and
then finally into a small tree and maybe
one day it'll be
a big business on its own and in fact
that's one of the mottos for one of your
initiatives and forgive my my
pronunciation of the Latin but Greta
team for Oct what does that mean to you
well it means uh step-by-step
ferociously and it's the motto for blue
origin
um and uh basically you can't skip steps
you have to put one foot in front of the
other things take time uh you there are
no shortcuts and but but you want to do
those steps with you know passion and
ferocity let's talk about failures I
know Amazon has had its shadow feelings
in fact I remember having been part of
some of them at Amazon
I'm cute is to know how do you think
about failure and how should we we deal
with failure when we see it
well
Amazon is the best place in the world to
fail
and the reason for that is we have a lot
of practice
nobody likes to fail by the way failure
even when you know it's important and
good it's embarrassing
it doesn't feel good we're all human we
had a good idea we thought it was a good
idea and nobody came to the party
that happens and here's the great thing
though
one success One winner can pay for
dozens and dozens of failures
and that is why it should fail one of
the great paradoxes of inventing at a
high level
is that you need to be an expert in your
domain area
and you need to have a beginner's mind
you absolutely need both of those things
the world is too complex to actually
just be a beginner so you know I can't
no matter how inventive I am I can't go
invent a new kind of brain surgery
you have to be a neurosurgeon you have
to already know all there is to know
about brain surgery and then take it to
the next level the problem is for many
people by the time they become true
experts they've lost that ability to see
things in a fresh way they've lost The
Beginner's mind
and so that's another thing you always
need to be stepping back and saying if I
I'm an expert I'm an expert in launch
vehicles or whatever it is
I I need to step back and say okay
if I were looking at this for the first
time what would I be seeing and noticing
these are just some of the things you
need to do to be innovative
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the one-on-one I did
recently with Grant check it out right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there true wealth cannot be created
working it could only be created
invested Elon Musk is completely invest
he has no cash and no houses